Arisa history was made this evening oh
my god
two ladies the final two dos dos how do
you feel about it I feel amazing about
it I mean five years in I feel like you
know I start to feel like well can I be
surprised I was so surprised by how this
season unfolded what an amazing end to a
season that had so many incredibly
strong females and so in Paris and Kayla
walked out of that house I was like here
for it season six we did it this was a
really tense episode it was really down
to the wire did you call it like could
you call this in advance that this was
going to happen I could call this about
a week ago
this is experience talking but I think
there were lots of people who were very
very surprised and it could have gone so
many so many different ways you know but
I think we had like the way it ended was
the way it was always supposed to end
you know
so I feel like everyone feels pretty
happy with their performance everyone
came out really joyous and that's what I
am so happy to see how are you gonna
feel not see these faces every single
day now it's gonna be weird I mean
there's gonna be times where I pick up
my phone to look at like live feet
updates and realize that there's no live
feeds because it's over and like what is
it what is this phone even for is what I
say to myself um but then you know BB 20
is gonna start in the summer and BB UK
starting and then maybe there'll be
another celebrity season and you know
who knows maybe we'll have a seventh
season so I'm excited
Big Brother around the air so you know
you said that you've got experience you
can sort of call things as before before
anyone else sees them
sometimes going into this season did you
did you ever expect that you'd get some
of the twists and turns and surprises
that we got um that I will say no when
we start I have no idea which way it'll
go we had like you saw the group of pre
Sheree members and like I also want to
watch that show like it hot and ruin
Hamza and Marin and Rosina and Erica and
Veronica like that in itself is a
fantastic show so that just shows you
the strength of the first half of our
game and then when you see a win like
this that's the strength of the second
half of the game
what has been your favorite thing about
this season favorite thing about this
season I liked getting to a final two
where people played very very different
games that I like to see because there's
no one way to play a big brother there's
no one way to win big brother kala
played the game in a very scary way she
linked up with someone that would
immediately make her a target right away
and she managed to like win every single
time she needed to win she has broken
the Big Brother Canada record for days
on slop 36 and there's no female that is
one more comps than kayla so seeing her
do that he's amazing and then seeing
Paris who only started pulling on her
wins at the very end of a of the season
and talked to the camera this whole time
and and and was vulnerable and showed
viewers like what was going right and
wrong in her game that's a crazy other
way to play so I'm I'm happy that our
show can reward both of those types of
gameplay before we go you know you were
with us with Facebook live on Monday and
you know as sort of the keeper of Big
Brother the keeper of all the secrets
people are paying close attention to
things you do and things you say here's
here's let me explain something to you I
operate on three timelines my operate on
Showtime like online timeline real-life
timeline so while I didn't want to spoil
he would won HOH which the online
timeline new TV timeline did not know so
I pull it back now that online people
were like she was talking to us she just
world that will was a big I did not but
it was really really fun for me to watch
the arguments going back and forth in
the phantom that was I'm not gonna say
that's one of them actually honestly one
of the best things about being part of
your brother about watching is like
seeing phantom you go oh oh fun and
people were like going back and forth
taking shots and I was just like
standing back like I love this LoZ
family